you don't mess with you se retrouvent
pour jouer à quelques gros jeux jeudi
groupe si d'habitude je dis petit et le
doubs je me suis changé c'était
peut-être pas mal on s'en bat les steaks
aux causes tout de suite avec vérité
voilà qui est une histoire de prince qui
veut retrouver sa princesse voit la
princesse qui se fait kidnapper en moto
voilà par un grand méchant notre soliste
une chèvre avec qui on peut parler en
faisant ça waouh belle moto lui vient
kidnappeurs princesse donc tu pas de
compliments s'te plaît c'est un méchant
garçon avec une moto et il a kidnappé la
belle princesse hockey et maintenant
peut-être que tu devrais aller l'a
sauvée tu ferais mieux de rattraper
tomber pays en voilà une bonne idée ou
toi cac 40 cède aussi pourquoi pas un
prince moderne à ça sonne comme un plan
juste besoin de trouver mon épée on doit
trouver cette [ __ ] c'est ça je dois je
trouvais une épée bordel je batte
rappelé hf6 nom et taper le méchant avec
la chèvre une fois une clé ou une clé
c'est ça mais pourquoi ce live [ __ ]
regarder il surfe le mail on est sur
l'herbe as insupportable ça te thor va
reprendre la pelle ça me semble être une
très bonne idée on va creuser dans la
terre pardon chèvre c'est trop c'est mon
gars ça se voit pas ça c'est pas pire
dans le cul de la chef par accident ça
va être fatale et attend ici je l'envoie
sur lui là où je suis sûr que ça qu'il
faut faire attention aux ça va sonner un
peu et nul au kef a juste que je lui
parle nickel moi je tape avant lui
parler c'est plutôt bizarre saluer ce
que tu veux mon épée qu'est ce que j'en
sais je suis un corbeau ok peut-être que
je peux 3 1 service et en retour tu veux
être mon épée séoul met un coup de pelle
direct quoi actuellement il ya quelque
chose que tu veux faire pour moi lui met
un coup de pelle la chèvre ici présentes
à manger quelque chose qui m'appartient
une pelle une peine pour toi table et
comment je peux l'avoir je sais pas
c'est dedans et ça besoin de sortir à
champignons aussi judas un truc
dégueulasse
albeau mire normalement voilà là là tu
vomis la non mais non je suis belle et
non mais c'est un chef j'ai un truc pour
toi tiens qu'est ce qu'elle fait qu'est
ce qu'elle fait est décédé à temps elle
se frotte aux toilettes là on va
regarder là je vais lui en amener plein
en faisant ça je m'allonge et je mène ma
complet que les choux mais ça on s'en
fout aller n'ont même plus atteint on
fait un effort aussi chef quoi ta du
chou qui te pointes les fesses tu le
manges même pas mange le ca la hoya un
fruit jaune à c'est peut-être ça
attendez tous les frissons bleu lui les
jaunes ils doivent pas bon ou alors il
est extrêmement bon il est en or vas tu
me diras tu manges de leur télé pas très
bien non plus mais lancer de belles nul
toi tout droit dans le cul de la chaîne
mais y'a un truc avec le q3 je vous le
dis vraiment je fais c'est ça au moins
ça trouve il est carrément trop beau
elle le paye tout vomi en europe dans le
cul est la manche et c'est moi la manche
et alors oui c'est un [ __ ] 9 tient
corbeau année on va l'envoyer dessus ça
avec nos lancers sont très bien depuis
le but de cette vidéo
3 mais votre mot de passe secret et 1 2
3 4
c'est une blague c'est une petite bonne
depuis trouvé ça du premier coup c'est
mon passe de quoi s'il te plaît à bala
les mesures doivent entrer avec un mot
de passe mon gars non y'a juste passe un
truc avec ce tableau
oui ça eh ben ça ne servira à rien 1 2 3
4 6 1 2 3 4
on me demanderait le jeudi quand même
celle de 3,4 s'il vous plaît c'est bon
on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le temps
on a la clé oui [ __ ] il n'a pas le
temps voyelles elle aussi la venue dans
le coup de sept chefs tout finit dans le
cul de cette chèvre et maintenant bah
alors oui on n'en faut pas qu'on va
tellement galéré en ont mais là vous
rigolez moi je rigole pas du tout quoi
pas un peu mais envoyé juste envoyer la
coupe de cheveux de cet homme au oui
elle est bien prise c'est une belle
prise
oui allez non à vos breton epb atx
poncet va tomber la préf ai-je dit oui
excuse moi je trouvais la tête aussi on
s'en va préfet oui où
allez y est c'est l'heure de passer au
jeu suivant majeur césure warning ok
donc apparemment si vous êtes
photosensible avancé sur la vidéo ou
alors aller sur une vidéo dédiée bouge
tout aussi bien c'est mal vu au hockey
c'est parti en live lors des gros flash
bien mais le jour
ouais ok d'accord faut que j'étudie les
tue j'étudie ça va trouver calmez-vous
la souplesse peu bref je dois améliorer
mon équipement rockets quoi et alors des
quêtes il ya desquels partout oui mais
monsieur à moi j'ai un boulot boulot
voilà je fais les cadets bono la fille
au jour on sait très bien alors qu'à des
pièges doit acheter des armes
ok ça marche tu bosses asselah
photosensible jeunesse l'écran
photosensible non c'est intense
je pense que le mec quoi l'écho des jeux
il avait pris un peu trop de red bull
est un peu trop de cocaïne [ __ ] en
masse avait partout dans son bureau
oui mais on va faire notre jeu c'est
parti jeu suivant on est maintenant sur
adams drague 32 qui est un jeu
d'infiltration voilà genre de jeu auquel
je paye tout forme et si on sait faire
la discrétion quand même assez faire
petit coup hop là je te casse le nettoie
j'arrivais papa voilà à mon gars c'est
sympa la discrétion alors par contre
faut que je prenne du loot voilà dans le
coffre de la voiture et du loot voilà
merci beaucoup ce très beau mot c'est
toi qui as je pense que aux caisses
quand je cours ils entendent mais mes
petites mes petits pas un puisque
chauffe du 36 donc ne peut-il pas du
coup je me vois tu ris tout de suite ou
pas de croquer le bâtard il a rigolé je
vous dis qu'il a rigolé o o
j'ai trop peur d'y aller tromper un quad
arrivants et face au chili où tu n'en
suis désolé que tu désolé tu prends toi
je suis un bateau on s'en fout je suis
désolé maman un mois un mois 2 le traver
il est là ghislaine carte
yes aaa dont jouit en bas à droite je
suis vraiment terrifié toi ta gueule
voilà il m'énerve urbain il m'énerve je
vais pas faire semblant il m'énerve suis
pas hypocrite ne m'énerve pas voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça a tu m'énerves
a été petit tête la même tête que tous
les autres d'ailleurs au taz absous je
me mettais au cou au monde off dans un
il ya du monde là bas
regardez là parfait mon gars là on
attend qu'ils passent parce que c'est un
travail d'attentes aussi être trop
discrétion c'est un travail qui se
travaille oui il est vrai j'essaie de
combler l'attend parce que là du coup on
se fait chier en tant que ce mec passe
donc il faut dire des choses moi je
pense que c'est le moment pour manger un
petit chocolat voilà un petit sapin le
bon bon tiens tu bats comme ça hein on y
retourne là il ya un piège
oh oh oh oh je veux faire le sale piège
me fait rire c'est par une porte il y
avait peut-être une carte sur le même
combat
ah non elle est là non c'est mon viseur
au la nullité du mec quoi quoi ils
prônent risque je n'ai pas de testicules
oui à vous êtes quand même par le
nouveau quai pas de moi déjà parce que
make sure testicules vous habille mal
maintenant au tournant dès qu'il arrive
pas or voilà regardez le bien regardez
le bien je vous dis et si vous arrivez à
le regarder dit ben oui les [ __ ] au
cid étincelle qui est aidée à toi a du
coup faut que j'aie tu as la main [ __ ]
merde
ah j'avais pas j'avais pas des coups de
chaud désolé je ne pouvais pas je vois
là je voulais pas me permettre c'est
là-bas la dernière porte la porte
rose il nous reste que deux balles merci
avoir joué près ses atours star tu
commences à douala on peut pas finir sur
ce à quoi ce pape ou s'il propose de
trouver un petit bonus comme ça en
équipe
oui on est bien on ne finit bien on est
serein voilà pour la rentrée en rendant
pardon je vais pas dire ce mot bienvenue
sur blade desk voilà un jeu dans lequel
on nous dit autre avenir alors qu'on
lance des couteaux sur un mec vivant à
peut-être un idiot finalement votation
les jo alors faut lancer des couteaux
c'est ça comme ça par exemple on a donc
mon avenir amoureux tu rencontreras
bientôt l'amour de ta vie un crapaud
nommé li dommage que les ne te
rencontrera jamais tu à venir avec ce
crapaud chic royer et bien sûr il est
pro monga ohlala non tant dans le sind
banane quand même nommé mec nickel quoi
en place en plein dedans en pavant le
penny comme on dit c'est dingue je vais
tweets sur life c'est le moment pour toi
de te tester arrête de te cacher sous
une table et va conquérir les mayas ou
une armoire mais une grande
on va rester sur l'armoire si pas mal
l'armoire 1 vous habille un tri 60 trucs
pour effrayer faut pas tuer ce contexte
en échec un énorme échec l'as réal je
sens bien voilà bienvenue en espace à
nickel
ils font ça aussi là haut et s'amusent
pas mal aux [ __ ] désolé mon gars est
mon avenir il est où dans l'histoire au
final love
les gens qui disent que tu ne devrais
pas faire des films pornos à la maison
si tu ne veux pas les mettre sur
internet du bruit qui m'a fait peur la
bouche pas qui a fait ça mais je ne
ferai jamais de porno à la maison ça
peut te rassurer vraiment donc les gens
qui disent que tu devrais pas faire de
pendant à la maison si ce n'est pas pour
les mettre sur internet sont idiots mais
tu devrais arrêter de les uploader sur
youtube où toi et ton espace héroïque
seront bannis oui ça marche
ok donc vous avez juste ramener un
fantôme dans l'appartement à part ça
tout va bien life tu échouera à tout ce
que tu essaieras mais ce n'est pas un
gros problème parce que tu ne le
remarquera même pas mais est-ce qu'un
jour j'ai un bel avenir [ __ ] entre
sortir et qui a craint pour faire un
film porno à la maison ait eue avec le
crapaud en plus [ __ ] échoue à tout ce
que j'entreprends mais ça va la mort
toujours ce contrôle tu décides toi même
du jour exact de la mort elle fait
simplement pas aujourd'hui où quelqu'un
accusera ce [ __ ] de jeu futur il est
bien au ballon c'est la voir cette vidéo
j'espère que vous a plus les cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude à ne pas jouer à ce jeu parce
que votre futur sera forcément nul et
c'est scandaleux
merci à vous regarder on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo dans
une nouvelle bouteille d'eau aussi ça
marche on sait jamais si quelqu'un réa
cette blague sache que tu es seul job du
monde
pis
oui